et cette boîte à poucave cette boîte
dans laquelle était cassé trois fois de
casser les trois fois dans laquelle les
chroniqueurs le public ou encore la
production donne des infos secrètes sur
les membres de l'équipe jean michel a
bloqué tous les numéros de la production
pour ne pas être dérangés pendant la
jeunesse pas tous sur une marine que
j'embrasse qu'elle a rien rhenatic et
son chef il est vrai qu'elle a tendance
à m'appeler un peu avant 17 heures ce
qui moi c'est pareil c'est vrai que
avant 17 heures on dort tous les jours
elle s'est en revanche va débloquer la
jolie ses messages fatou déteste les
poils et pile elle même gilles sérieux
ouais ouais et vous des plis le fath oui
oui
ah ouais elle vous épiler face elle fait
elle le fait très bien
vous serez d'amour même la siffler même
le siffle pas encore mais on arrive bien
d'accord mais il allait si bien super
bien si vous voulez le peux vous épiler
un jour dans ce département
mais par exemple il sait pas auto
balance et donc qui peut savoir que
fatto epil gilles il s'est confié à une
balance ça doit être terrible que c'est
vous et vous non plus
[Rires]
comptez vous allez tout balancer comme
ça mais il faut bien que je ne vous dis
pas la nourrir isabelle a dansé collé
trop serré avec un chroniqueur en marge
d'un tournage quoi ah bon c'est quoi
cette histoire ça c'est toi moi il
paraît qu'on a la vidéo c'est qui oui je
les ai vus je m'appelle la vidéo c'est
quand même nous a saisis non moi je
balance penche pas tendance à 6,1
balance égale un board à la vidéo ben
voyons
un jour il me fait pas lancé gérard moi
je vais vider
[Musique]
il faut
où
[Musique]
c'est vrai surtout ce que je vois c'est
qu'isabelle est magnifique sans livrer
sans déconner et où ce fait si elle lui
sans rigoler c'est la première fois
qu'ils se réveillent avant 16 heures
deux partout partout non mais c'est tout
ça rigolait ouais non mais on était
jeunes et trottinettes apparemment la
sienne était pas lectrique on va se
régaler est et c'est vous non on dit
bien franchement j'en aurais dit non
c'est pas lui dire ouais les mecs et
gallas a été d effet spécial ça se voit
tu vois que c'est fou ben c'est ça que
tu fous de ma gueule à laisser aller on
adore on a d'autres trucs on a des bons
trucs aujourd'hui les dossiers des de
cyril une fois annoncé et si tout va
bien si vous voulez pas le but voyez
vous c'est quoi alors si reed s'est un
peu dans le prolongement de ce qui s'est
passé avait pas songé papilles en fête
dont la prochaine fois chez moi je
balance tout le temps ils sont je vous
donne pas la fille vous arriveriez même
pas lire avec vos yeux c'est pourquoi
j'ai des petits yeux c'est à force de
prendre le chocolat
en tout cas c'est donc ça passe donc
alors cyril avec et il aime bien aller
aux toilettes des bureaux il les remet à
l'elysée c'est un mec qui aime bien les
chevaux le dire voilà fin et il était
dans sa voiture la nature balades nature
ont failli et des moments pour faire
quelques mois plus bas qu'à tout le
temps josip ans et donc aidé dans sa
voiture et il avait une grosse envie de
fakka mais y avait pas de faute n'y
avait pas de toilettes à disposition
donc est ce qui fait tourner tout
naturellement ce grand garçon de 40 ans
il n'y a pas de toilettes dans sa
voiture était garée dans son pantalon
non mais ça fait 14 ans pantalon et non
il ya donc chez nous les aubaines
absolument dire une chose au patrimoine
chez dans son île a fait caca dans son
pantalon il est allé en courant chez lui
il a enlevé le pantalon et des blagues
lâché avec le caca occupe à la douche et
il a tout enlevé avec de l'eau et du
savon
c'est pas vraiment petits bouchons alors
l'histoire le raconte en compte est la
vrai j'avais des sièges en alcantara
j'avais rendez vous j'ai déjà j'avais
rendu avec la patronne de l'époque
j'avais rendez vous avec la patronne de
françois l'époque et j'ai été jetée
obligé d'y aller voilà je débutais du
voyage avait pas grand chose à faire et
elle m'envoie elle m'amène dans un
restaurant qui très très loin de chez
moi et je suis sur le périph c'est le
préfet va là sur le périph
et là je me dis franchement il reste
encore douze portes ça va te coupent les
frères je sais que je ne tiendrai pas à
ses côtés mois avant la porte depuis un
moment je suis cammas et ses yeux tu
mets la musique et où tu vois tu fais
genre tu qui est en fait heurté au
nombre ont fait un championnat parce que
tu sais que tu étais payam du tout vous
frères un ballon vos confrères mais
jeter comme asvam avait un truc de ouf
c'est à dire si je m'étais tête
l'assisté cola et la page mais la
musique les gens le guide et un moment
je vois je suis à 6 cette porte de chez
moi indique obg dit ce qu'on appelle
nicomaque j'ai tout envoyé et j'ai fait
les sept portes comme as et vous étiez
mieux après avec la de mer mais avec la
musique entend développer
hélas frère j'arrive en bas de chez moi
bon bien sûr je me gare pas je me mets
jamais la voiture comme ça là je me
déshabille entièrement je sors à wald je
prends toutes les affaires je les teste
dans une poubelle et je vais dans mon
immeuble à poil je suis à walf avec des
baskets dans l'immeuble avec de l'eau de
mer par est hélas hélas médias c'est un
gars qui aime bien et donc voilà
et donc je suis rentré et après bah
voila j'ai heureusement j'ai rencontré
personne j'avais qu'une peur c'est de me
faire arrêter par la police abat vous
savez premier sur le pays pendant droit
de sortir avant sa période de neige ps
on peut sortir avant ça n'est un besoin
et moi j'avais peur que les policiers me
demande est-ce que vous avez vos papiers
jeudi par contre si vous en avez sa mort
[Applaudissements]
rigolade ce que j'avais des sièges
journal content mais votre voiture et
abris savez ça avait transpercé et y en
avait et j'ai quand je suis allé au
garage pour de la voiture j'ai dit aux
gars d'à je suis pas chez prêté la
voiture à un ami je pense qu'il a fait
là où il a raison c'est vrai que ça vous
est pas venu à l'esprit de vous dire je
peux peut-être sortir avant année dans
un café prendre un verre d'eau un café
et puis occupé les toilettes du
quatrième voyage comme l'essence est
chère
non mais j'ai dit non franchement j'ai
dit nico mots et vous voulez que je vous
dise et ben si j'ai pas fait ça on
n'aurait pas raconte aujourd'hui c'est
une expérience à vivre voilà non mais je
vous le voilà à l'est